[Music]
hey everyone its Peter Brown here to
talk about Zelda breath of the wild and
our full review will not be here until
March 2nd next Thursday than the
meantime here are impressions of the
first five hours of the game if the
entirety of breath of the wild maintains
the beauty and variety seen in its
opening hours it will be a strong
contender for the best Zelda game of all
time and I say this fully aware that any
new Zelda game comes with a hefty dose
of hype and anticipation throw in a
console launch on top of that and you
wouldn't be blamed for sounding the
hyperbole alarm however my enjoyment
isn't tied to holding a shiny new piece
of plastic or simply swinging a sword as
link breath of the wild is an exciting
game for it's incredible landscapes and
how with minimal instruction you're
allowed to find your footing as you go
you have to contend with a dense rule
set in which nearly every decision you
make must be cross-referenced with your
surroundings and because of this
demanding yet satisfying atmosphere you
feel like you're constantly learning
often through failure and death survival
let alone progress is a major concern
you have to understand your physical
limitations wander too far up a snowy
mountain without the proper gear and you
will freeze to death in short order if
you dive into a lake you better pray you
have enough stamina to make it to the
other side you can also scale cliffs now
but you may find yourself stuck mid
climb if the weather takes a sudden turn
for the worse
your ability to get a foothold is
drastically reduced in the rain enemies
of course are another chief concern
rushing into battle is a non option
against anything other than a single
enemy to face a squad of 5 enemies and
not die all it takes is a few hits you
will have to make the most of your
surroundings if you see a red barrel
find a way to set it ablaze
or perhaps wait for nightfall so you can
sneak up on enemies and kill them while
they sleep experimenting and learning
new tactics will get you far but you
also need to be active and aware when
clashing swords or Spears link is
capable of pairing an incoming attack
with the press of a button at the right
time in a brief window forcing you to
pay attention to every move your enemy
you can also dodge and backflip away
from an attack which will leave an enemy
vulnerable if they wish enemies with
pull arms or spears present a different
type of challenge how do you get in
close with a considerably shorter weapon
in hand well by jumping over their
weapon and attacking from overhead get
another maneuver you have to learn on
your own
where battles are a tough nut to crack
at first in a short span of time you
learn how to overcome these obstacles
through necessity and experimentation a
process that is consistently rewarding
despite the number of deaths you incur
along the way every weapon in the game
thus far is acquired by defeating
enemies you therefore come across a lot
of potential weapons both in number and
variety you need to be mindful of their
durability which is only detailed in
words ambiguous weapon durability is the
one shortcoming of breath of the wild
thus far most of the swords spears clubs
and shields found in the early hours of
the game break after just a few fights
it isn't always easy to reconcile
preserving a cool weapon versus fighting
with something that's more common yet
weak but you don't always have a choice
it will be interesting to see how this
plays out in the long term the hope is
that you find more durable weapons that
can have a permanent spot in your
inventory but that remains to be seen at
the moment beyond satisfying your
curiosity exploration is driven by
shrines puzzle driven dungeons littered
across the world they are bite-sized
lasting only a few minutes apiece but
they deliver a completely different tone
compared to the outside world and at the
start of some shrines you'll be granted
a new power known as a rune these
include bombs that can be generated
resource free under a cooldown timer but
you also gain the ability to summon
pillars of ice from bodies of water and
move metallic objects by controlling a
magic magnetic orb tethered to your body
but each shrine is guaranteed to net you
a spirit orb and these act as a currency
of sorts that you can trade in by
praying at a statue to upgrade your
health or stamina meters so far picking
one over the other has been the hardest
decision to make and breadth of the wild
shrines are common but not so common
that you can expect to quickly balance
out your stats with new spirit orbs this
all sounds like a lot to manage and it
is but damn if it doesn't feel good to
play a Zelda game with so many variables
and opportunities available from the
start all this is to say nothing of the
light-hearted events that populate the
world and how they brighten up a dreary
trip through rain and fog after a
hard-fought battle people are affable
and cheeky and animals prove to be a
soothing and beneficial distraction
nuzzle a dog with your face and become
instant
friends tame a wild horse and make it
your own or swipe at a chicken to make a
drop an egg that you can use in your
next meal the stories being shared among
those playing breath of the wild at
GameSpot are all vastly different and
exciting even though we're playing the
same game we're all jealous of one
another breath of the wild embodies the
freedom and danger that made the first
Zelda game so enthralling but it also
captures the feeling of awe that came
when ocarina of time hit the scene in
this case by layering untold variables
into seemingly every facet of the
experience based on our early
impressions it's safe to say that breath
of the wild will forever change what
people expect from the future of the
Zelda series
[Music]